PROTECT THE SOUTH FROM A
NORTHERN INVASION.
IN A STRANGE AND LONELY PLACE.
>> FOR YOUR PROTECTION.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU GUYS ARE
SAFE.
>> WE'RE GOING HERE ON THE
ACTUAL LINE TO GO INTO NORTH
KOREA.
I HAVE TO WALK THIS WAY.
WE CAN'T SHOOT LEFT OR RIGHT.
WE CAN ONLY SHOOT FORWARD.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESTRICTIONS ON
OUR CAMERA.
WE PASS SOP ANTI-TANK EXPLOSIVES
AND WE'RE ABOUT TO GO INTO THESE
BLUE ROOMS AND INTO THE NORTH
KOREA LINE.
THEY STILL MEET IN THESE ROOMS.
>> THE LAST KNOWN VISIT WAS
2008.
>> THE MICROPHONES ARE WHAT
DEFINES THE LINE.
IT SEEMS TO EASY.
IT'S JUST ONE STEP BUT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE MILITARIZATION
AND THE BARBED WIRE IT'S FAR
FROM EASY.
THIS CONCRETE SLAB IS LITERALLY
THE BORDER.
WE'RE SHOOTING IT FROM NORTHERN
SIDE, 17" BY 5".
CONCRETE.
IT'S BEEN HERE SINCE 1953.
THEY DON'T USE E-MAIL.
THEY DON'T USE A PHONE.
THERE'S A PHONE BUT IT RINGS AND
RINGS AND THE NORTH KOREAEN
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THEY COMMUNICATE BY BULL HORN.
IF I WERE TO DO THAT OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING TO STEP OVER THAT LINE,
HERE, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO ME?
>> ALL THESE SOLDIERS WOULD MAKE
AN ATTEMPT TO STOP YOU.
ESPECIALLY ME.
ONCE YOU GET OVER THERE,
QUEWE CAN
NO LONGER HELP YOU.
>> WHAT WOULD THEY DO?
>> PROBABLY GRAB YOU.
>> TO SERVE HERE THEY HAVE TO BE
5'9", WHICH IS TALLER THAN
AVERAGE AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM HAS A BLACK BELT IN TAE
KWON DO.
THEY STAND HERE EVERY DAY AND
STARE AT EACH OTHER.
THE CONCRETE BUILDING IS WHERE
NORTH KOREAN TOURISTS CAN COME
TO VISIT THE DMZ.
A LOT OF CHINESE COME TO THE
NORTH KOREAN SIDE.
THE SOLDIER STANDS THERE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THEY DON'T KNOW HIM NAME BUT
THEY REFER TO HIM AS BOB.
WE'RE SURROUNDED BY NORTH KOREA
NOW?
>> YES.
ALL THIS TREE LINE AND AROUND
THAT ROAD AND BACK IS ALL NORTH
KOREA.
>> IT'S ALL NORTH KOREA AND
WHERE WE ARE IS SORT OF ONE
LITTLE SAFE SPOT BUT THIS IS ALL
MINED AS WELL?
>> YES, THERE'S A THOUSAND MINES
WITHIN THIS AREA.
>> THERE'S A CEMENT WALL TO